[Music]
hi my name is Tom and I'm a copywriter
I read commercials I'm Kevin we're I'm a
creative director at Geauga science in
New York and we I'm Erin we have
commercials luckily we can give you some
good advice just buying the space and
the Super Bowl to four million dollars
there's you look at it as like okay we
have a captive audience of like hundreds
of millions of people what is the
craziest thing that we can do just to
get people talking the people's
commercial exactly three ingredients to
be an awesome Superbowl commercial what
I think it's got to be original Super
Bowls they always have celebrities like
magic puppies honey she went you is that
kind of a super over so they all have
some product truth in them there was the
Volkswagen the force commercial where
the little kid dressed up as Darth Vader
and tried to make things happen with his
mind and he goes out and he goes like
that's the car in the debt load started
the car and the kid freaks out it's
really cute for the Volkswagen it does
sort of feel like the force when you
remote start a car the the Snickers
Betty White commercial that was a real
classic one that you like playing tackle
football better
Snickers hunger does transform you into
a different person and each rate is less
of a product truth in a more immediate
Ruth it's just a monkey dancing wearing
a knee trade shirt for 20 seconds and
then it says well we just wasted a
million dollars how's your money people
watch the Super Bowl very aware of how
much the commercials cost and they think
about whether that was worth that much
money so it's tapping into what people
are already thinking it's like there's
no rule except like what works the price
let's talk about your current Super Bowl
commercial it the avocados from Mexico
commercial it's perfect world we shield
the bad out and kept the good in but of
course they're just people so we're
gonna screw it up yeah just fluctuates
for months and months and months and so
finally you wind up with that one idea
that made it free using celebrities in
ways that are unexpected I think is it
is a really good way to go at things
there was a Squarespace one last year
with John Malkovich he was very upset
because someone else had registered John
Malkovich calm and it was just a super
simple idea kind of hinges on a little
bit on like star power and believability
and scale I was on a team that made the
Tourism Australia commercial which
involved pretending to make a movie
called Denby that's me Roy Dundee yeah
Hollywood is kind of rebooting every
single movie from the 80s Crocodile
Dundee kinda stands out as one that
hasn't been brought back we wanted
people to think that we were actually
making a real movie Danny McBride is
such an unlikely choice to play the son
of Crocodile Dundee which is intentional
there Mike nothing to see here Matt just
get the green Shane really became the
character on set and it was just
constantly riffing and improvising and
doing the lines better than we gave him
and a lot of the moments that ended up
in the final cut were him riffing Super
Bowl spots the process of making one is
great I mean look at the pretty success
that Doritos just happen for years just
very like sourcing big visuals like drop
people in but we haven't acted up with
some sort of substance and contents
another key to the Vegas commercial is
you have an excellent making it equal
certain area by watching it totally
making a Super Bowl commercial is kind
of like making a diamond it's a really
intense process it's it's months and
months of work because the prize is so
great it's so stressful but at the end
you have a beautiful diamond which is a
commercial
[Music]